je sais pas ce que je fais du pas
correct j'ai perdu mon influence tête
qu'ils étendent accroché le manteau
d'encore ce que ça prend des enfants
avec une cabine ils ont fait du trou
dans le traîneau j'ai pris une balle
il ya un nombre croissant de jeunes qui
prennent de mauvaises décisions presse
l'armée des états unis aimeraient faire
appel à vos services
je comptais pas renouveler l'expérience
nous avons conclu une entente de deux
mois avec l'armée américaine le
capitaine jacobs va vous informer de
tous les changements qui s'opèrent
rendant lui c'est en plus de ces
quelques règles nous allons élever le
niveau de sécurité du site est-ce que
vous avez des questions oui c'est un
jour de joie nous fabriquerons haussier
pas des joueurs je veux tu le père noël
quel est le but de votre vie dit bien en
vacances chasse et bien tué quelque
chose aux travailleurs sacré appétit
c'est pour ça que les mythes avic
pluvieux questionnaire écrit lui aussi
près pareil non c'est le fait de donner
six cartes semaine
je suis venu d'arracher la tête gros pot
crafted premier je crois que j'ai eu
c'est job parce que je suis grand et
joyeuse
non pas ces ordures de quoi tu es
capable oui madame je te ferai des
biscuits pour la route
[Musique]
lui si je n'ai rien reed man est clair
et bien pire elle peut vous arracher le
packaging coup
[Musique]
et un tonnerre d'applaudissements pour
notre ami al vous savez quelle
différence y lit en train de le fit
l'air et al capone
hitler est mort
cappone vie comme un roi en floride et
démord pas qu'un peu j'ai des raisons
croire qu'ils nous roule dans la farine
qu'est-ce qui se passe selon nos
informations votre client pourrait avoir
caché au fisc une très grosse somme
d'argent
c'est bon tu peux arrêter ton cinoche
tu as fait venir des sbires qui se
baladent partout
[Musique]
un gars comme toi
sap erp à 10 millions de dollars
je peux peut-être la même parler
on va faire un carnage je vous préviens
[Musique]
on s'était fait la promesse qu'un beau
jour on serait puissant
[Musique]
ce qui définit vraiment un homme
c'est comment il traite sa famille
[Musique]
beaucoup de gens se demandent ce qui
s'est passé la nuit dernière entre vous
et ce garçon là rien écouté a pas
écoutés
si tu me touches encore tu brûleras est
impossible
[Musique]
je me croyais et maintenant
ça nous est arrivé comment j'en sais
rien
savoir qu'il est la seule chose qui
importe de le retrouver rapidement et de
le mettre hors d'état mené
aidés qui pourrait tessa match entre le
rire il ne faut surtout pas qu'ils
atteignent une ville vous comprenez il
arrive parfois que de mauvaises choses
arrivent à de bonnes personnes
pas ça ne nous fait pas affaire touche
pas tu n'allais peut-être auxquels
l'accès l'abattre
tu pourrais faire d'autre si tu es
capable de contrôler ça
yan turcotte et ex martins pêcheurs de
taille
[Musique]
samedi
c'est vrai
comment
[Musique]
this is life and talent
alors ta nouvelle maison montre
attentive montre moi tes yeux noirs
toujours entre péquistes de sa mère il
me parle que je sais très bien que c'est
pas de ta faute tu pouvais voir si tu
veux un sacre à rien puis l'enjeu ici
c'est l'homme à l'animal
lumignons comment il s'appelle mister
tiens c'est un cadeau de la forêt
où
plus cela a pu percevoir tu connais les
pokémon
si l eau en métro coeur pur a aucune
raison qu'ils deviennent méchants c'est
quoi ça tient dans tachon gare papa il
est trop milieu ce peuple est un peu le
quart des douits
victoria elle parle bienvenue dans la
famille tutelle
hal est méconnaissable disney a dit
bonjour est ce qu il fait des bêtises il
a déjà mangé mes pantoufles bien
d'autres petits chiens bergers des
grosses pas quand même ouais
enfin je regarde victoria voit une
petite fille qui va être très heureuse
parce qu'elle a un super papa
allo solitaire qui rend si vous avez des
bêtes on les mettra l'argent non pas de
but mais ici c'est sûrement qu'en chine
c'est pas un chien c'est forcément un
loup
c'est un prédateur pas mâché ses mots
quand l'homme il est menacé il était
fort c'est pas juste mais c'est comme ça
[Musique]
l'injuste à l'entente monsieur qu'est ce
que vous voulez que je fasse je suis ici
pour accuser un homme qui se trouve au
sommet de ce pouvoir corrompu
cet homme c'est le président park et que
devrions nous faire qui ce traître on va
l'attraper et on va le transformer en
engrais pour le jardin je vous le dis
moi c'est bon je m'en occupe vous avez
mon soutien
faites ce qui vous semble le réduire en
supplie le président de te pardonner
combien de temps est-ce qu'il lui reste
avant de se faire dégager par les états
unis
park est finie
les choses vont changer
je vais tout faire pour
les sommes ont une personnalité les
nations ont une dignité
le président c'est le pays et moi je
protège le pays qui ne sait pas que ça
remplit comme une jeanne berline
toi et moi on était des garçons de
course pour lui monsieur ne déclaraient
pas la loi martiale est ce que c'est une
menace au cambodge ils sont sacrifiés 3
millions de gens sans réfléchir alors
enfui en 2 millions avec des temps
quand est ce que le pays sera débarrassé
d'eux est ce que ça changera le monde le
monde changera tout seul
monsieur je vous en prie essayer d'avoir
une vision globale
et non pas les
ils respirent tout seuls dans leur salle
[Musique]